you decided to run up against run
against ilhan ilhan so tell us how you
really feel about ilhon for some that
don't know your true feelings about her
well i think she's in on it i think
she's a
globalist
i really deep down i think that she's a
security state asset
i asked myself who got out of somalia in
the 90s and i grew up in minneapolis so
i'm very familiar with the somali
community growing up in public school i
grew up with a bunch of somali kids
and have many friends you know growing
up that were somali um loyal friends
good people um so i'm not saying
anything about somalians in a general
sense but when i think about who got out
of somalia it's the same people that we
left behind in afghanistan
there were people that helped us when we
were there
and her father
is rumored to have been
a rebel
during the time
when we took people out of somalia
and a lot of her sentiments and actions
line up with that i mean who do we think
can just go to cashmere in the middle of
a uh
geopolitical tinderbox that that's
happening right there and uh meet with
not only the new prime minister of
pakistan but the former prime minister
of pakistan with no government clearance
with no help from the state department
first of all it's a lie that she didn't
get help from the state department but
even with the help from the state
department in that sense in a covert
manner
that's a security state operation in
many regards and so you know she she
poses herself as this democratic
socialist or you know this this
socialist or far leftist women's rights
activist
racism protected whatever you wanted
whatever you want to say whatever you
know whatever day it is
but really they're running a scam and i
saw it and it offended me because i'm
from the community and our
representation should represent people
um and and the biggest scam is is what i
saw coming down the hatch with the nba
right and not to go backwards but to to
to encapsulate and end my nba story with
my my anxiety was really existential
my anxiety was to say that there's a
global corporate community
and that the nba is a watering hole for
a global corporate community
they're like the cinequanon of globalism
you were saying that back then
oh yeah go pull it up i mean you pull up
the sports illustrated articles i'm
saying this is a global corporate
community this isn't just a basketball
league this is every industry in the
entire world from here to beijing
represented
in a financial interest
and when they say mental health is not
important they're saying the human
condition isn't important and it was a
pretext for their partners their
corporate partners such as big tech
to be predatory around human psychology
to weaponize dopamine
against the average person and that is
what they've done and the nba knew it
back then but not only the nba
their wall street
hedge fund
co-conspirators overlords they knew it
20 years ago
right and so you know that's that
rightful angst that kind of gets woven
in and misrepresented where it's like oh
you're just a kid who
is a prima donna you want special you
want special accommodations you want to
be treated differently than everybody
and that's that's why you're asking for
this and no no the reason why i'm asking
for it is much much deeper than most
people
wake up in the morning make their coffee
check the morning paper and look at the
stats maybe bet by noon want to deal
with
and it's that absence of wanting to deal
with it that that
that people like ilhan capitalize on
they exploit that how does somebody like
that get elected
um
lies help from the mainstream media
um
also you know that
the uh
localized identity politics she was sold
to the average somali that says hey a
somali-american just like you
achieving
this next step to actually represent a
constituent because there is no
there's no american race the way there
is a german or a french person we're
from everywhere didn't she almost lose
like by two or three thousand votes
tyler then she almost it was a close
race it was a close race that's why they
sold that but to your point that's maybe
on the initial election but she's been
re-elected how many times three times no
that look so like at some point the
people in minneapolis minnesota are
gonna have to all right we either like
this person or we don't i'm no fan of
ilhan omar but she's a representative
she's not a senator the people in her
district have to keep supporting her or
not
let's talk about that let's get one
thing straight
i just ran to become the united states
congressman from our fifth congressional
district i lost in a primary
by a thousand votes
to a uniparty
globalist
republican establishment candidate
you get the government you deserve
that's the reality you get the
government you deserve and
increasingly we
like our politics with french fries and
ilhan gives you everything that you need
to feel good about your politics with
friendship but isn't that just plain
politics royce like for instance for you
correct me if i'm wrong you've aligned
yourself with steve bannon yeah yes or
no yes so how palatable is that to the
people of minnesota maybe if you're in
alabama using them as an example hell
yeah let's get behind steve bannon let's
do it what's the you know
sentiment in minnesota a very
liberal-ish type state super liberal who
all right or city the outstanding yes
well every city in america literally
every major city votes blue most rural
votes read not even minnesota not hawaii
is the most liberal state new york
minneapolis specifically but when you
align yourself with steve bannon just
that name alone people are going to be
like yeah i don't know about that royce
sorry about that buddy well even worse
than that they don't say they don't know
they go they just write it off they
write me off that's my point but and i
think that when you lose by a thousand
votes
doesn't that come back to bite you in
the ass no no no no no see no absolutely
not tell us why
sacred honor and i'm going to keep going
back to it as as many times as necessary
because
this is the great crisis of politics
whatever i need to say wherever i am to
win the game is the ultimate goal
and when you play the game like that
it's kind of an american or post-modern
business practices when by any means
we we have to win we have to continue we
have to move on we have to go upward and
onward
um but it's egregious for for morality
or ethics or ideas
and that's why most people especially in
politics have betrayed their ideas
across time because their idea is i need
to say whatever it is that will appeal
to a person to get me elected when
really
your leaders your elected officials
should stand for things things they
really believe in things that are true
first and foremost but things they
really believe in and then be able to
convince you that you should believe in
them so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]